the heir apparent to the british crown
is usually known as the prince of wales
but did you know that the prince holds a
number of other titles as well
in order of precedence we first have the
title duke of cornwall
which is the oldest dukedom in england
having been created in 1337 and granted
to edward the black prince
unlike the prince's other titles this
one comes with specific privileges and
responsibilities
the title holder is given 150 000 acres
of land in southern england that land
and its assets net the prince 20 million
pounds a year
the next title is duke of rothsie
which is the title often used when the
prince is in scotland it was originally
held by the crown prince of scotland but
since the merging of the crowns of
england and scotland in 1604
the title is held by the prince of wales
the title earl of chester is directly
linked to the title prince of wales and
is generally given to the heir at the
same time as his princely title
next the titles earl of carrick and
baron of renfrew were traditionally held
by the prince of scotland and so are now
held by the prince of wales
one of the more interesting titles is
lord of the isles it was originally held
by the medieval leaders of these islands
the mcdonald's but in the 15th century
king james iv of scotland seized the
lands and the title lord of the isles
was thereafter granted to the scottish
prince
the last title somewhat strangely is
actually another princely one the prince
and great steward of scotland the two
parts of this title are technically
separate but are always combined in
legislation it traditionally had domains
over only a part of scotland the
principality of scotland
this video is a footnote of sorts for a
previous video of mine outlining the
history of the title prince of wales you
can watch that video here
you